[Music]
you guys know how everyone's
dream is to make money while you sleep
that pillow money passive income baby
let's go everyone's dreaming
i thought it was just like you make
money like sleeping and people are
watching you ding ding ding
ding ding there was a guy this guy in
china who has
found fame because he initially live
streamed himself
sleeping to see if he snored throughout
the night and when he woke up
he found that he had about eight hundred
thousand new followers what though
eight hundred thousand okay what's he
how is he sleeping what am i doing wrong
maybe he sleeps comfortably i'm not
getting any views when i sleep or maybe
his eyes are so asian that he's actually
awake
and he's like having really deep
conversations
but people think he's asleep is this
this new genre
like like mukbang but for sleeping asmr
for this guy
so his name is yuan sun and
he is an amateur actor
and so looks comfortable cute yeah he
looks like a drooler
he's sleeping on a hello kitty pillow
does his pillow have cute eyes
yeah it's like the other side of his eye
so he's hot his eyes going down and the
the pillow's going up actually if you
compare it to a mukbang it makes sense
right because people put those on so it
feels like they have someone to eat with
so maybe people are just like
lonely people like no people are
sleeping and so it feels like someone's
sleeping next to them
i'm doing it oh wow his eyes got way
bigger yeah he looks cuter when he's
sleeping oh [ __ ] no
really i think he's cute right there
yeah he looks like a kid
so when he woke up and he realized he
got all this faint he was like what the
yeah he looks confused right there yeah
so he so because he's an amateur actor
he decided to create like short
form contents dope which is him acting
but when he live streams himself acting
people are like
when are you going to go to sleep i'm
following his ass that's so
funny that is amazing you're like a dude
it's your bedtime man come on
get with it what you go viral for is
what you are a slave to yeah
exactly so he feels asleep to it so now
he's like softcore
poor girl he's like but i'm the method
actor i've been trained to do this they
don't give a [ __ ] about that
i just suck 10 dicks now everyone wants
to see me suck dicks all the time
just cause i did it on camera a couple
of times this guy got up to 18.5 million
views
oh my god so that's why like he's trying
to offer his viewers other types of
content
but they they leave the chat immediately
that's the best type of content yeah
you're gonna do it anyway
you know what he should do he should try
acting with his eyes closed yeah
he's like i know this is my brand so
like you know i'll try this out because
people are probably following him so
it could help them sleep and they're
like why the [ __ ] are you acting you're
energizing me right now
what could he act a camera too it's like
what is he doing monologues i know he's
doing shakespeare in spanish
yeah it's like monologues [ __ ] funny
so he's saying that this
he thinks that this is just very very
temporary the only reason why people are
watching him is because of the whole
coronavirus quarantine thing where
people are required to stay at home so
because of that reason all of these like
chinese social media sites have seen a
crazy increase
in activity because everyone's working
do you think this cat sleeps for 29
minutes anyways
he's like hey good guys don't forget
check out oliver.com
[Laughter]
and all of his like blankets and pillows
they have sponsors all over
he pulls his things down it's like
bluechew.com
he's like sorry guys i gotta go to the
bathroom i'll be right back he puts a
like we'll be right back card
everything that's weird i know he's
honestly man
this is this is tiff's dream this is
this is my dream
i would love it for gina's dream this is
literally but she never sleeps
oh yeah you're right never mind this is
my dream
but yeah so he's like i said he doesn't
want to keep doing it he's just like
no like i this feels weird like i don't
want to
i just did it once to see if i snore it
and then [ __ ] now i'm but why live
stream it dude yeah why don't you just
record it
is he like do you think he's bitching to
his friends he's like oh i gotta make so
much content this weekend i'm [ __ ]
exhausted
he's like i don't even want to sleep he
starts getting bed sores this is a
[ __ ] youtuber who i better never hear
talk about how tired he is
[Laughter]
he's like guys i need a break from
social media because they work so hard
sleeping too much yeah i need to go to
work everyone shut up yeah
you know you get the virtual gifts
during these live streams so he's made
about eleven thousand dollars
what the [ __ ] is this idiot's problem
why is he rejected do we
[ __ ] embrace it it's because he wants
to be known as a serious actor
yeah you broke [ __ ] watch wow this is
the problem with tubers just accept your
brand and you're the sleep guy now
deal with it yeah okay i'll take it oh
yeah give it to me well he's not on
youtube he's on a chinese streaming
platform called
doing i'm getting on that so different
you're not allowed
so he's a live streamer he doesn't do
ian is a
like a streaming platform oh i see kind
of like twitcher i guess
oh okay but that's for gaming like
people who are the gamer guys and
they're like i'm an entertainer and it's
like
whatever [ __ ] gamer it's fine you do
entertain people as you're gaming
but embrace your [ __ ] embrace what you
do right right instead of rejecting the
fact that they're gamers
yeah that's true because in the very
beginning a lot of people were like i'm
not a youtuber
right mm-hmm i'm a musician it's lame
i'm a [ __ ] youtuber i don't give a
[ __ ]
yep where am i where what has paid me
for a long long time
youtube but no but i'm so sick like why
am i sick of it because like i get i get
hit up for a lot of uh
non-scripted stuff hosting [ __ ] because
you know like i'm like charming and [ __ ]
yeah uh i think you're charming i'm good
at reading a teleprompter i'm good at
eating food on camera and good eating
food on camera
but it's like i wanna act steve i know
we'll put you in some space you want to
do scripted things
but you can be that just make that a
dash youtuber dash
oh yeah it's all in there musician dash
but you have done that
you have done that yeah yeah i know
you've been on tv but sometimes i'm
hesitant to i don't want to become
mario lopez you feel me i do feel you
why because because i put a shotgun in
my mouth
look at that handsome no no no not about
that he's all saved by the bail
but hosting extra and having to smile
that much i'm out
i'm out every time ten years down the
line and
you're like the king of hosting like
that's dude everyone approached
you're the go-to guy would you be like
[ __ ] man your current day regis
i would i would i would be of course i
would feel blessed but you know in my
head a little bit i'd be like
because that's not what you wanted you
wanted will smith style acting and
variety life yeah i didn't give a [ __ ] i
just want money and play
i feel that money power [ __ ] that's it
baby buddy papa
nomination no we'll just keep we'll just
we'll just transfer our currency
pesos power [ __ ] i convert it and we'll
convert is everything
because if it's vessels it's way more
too more zero
i'm like that kid i'm like give me that
hundred and dollars
so i could [ __ ] wave it like flossy
zimbabwe dollars that's the [ __ ] right
there some [ __ ] rupees
yeah oh yeah not euros or pounds it's
too small
club med beads am i right she beats
that's what they call it
yeah they do beads in club med whack
yeah is that the old people thing beads
beads old people club men pretty much
yeah oh
mardi gras you don't know about club med
you don't know club med geo
i don't [ __ ] can you educate me and
you're not a conspiracy corner either oh
[ __ ] i'd rather not know about club med
you don't want to know about club med no
i don't know about club
let me tell you guys the facts about
columbus i thought it was old people
[ __ ]
it is all i remember is snoopy in the
commercials tell me what the [ __ ] this
is is that right it's like a it was a
club that existed in the bahamas i think
it still does
yeah i went when i was like five years
old because my uncles uh god gave us a
present
for that um you were blessed enough to
go to club med we went to club memphis
i remember seeing commercials for club
med when i was a little kid but i had no
idea what it was
i still don't know what you guys talking
about i remember like sandals it's like
a sandal it's like a resort thing and
then
there it's like cool because you don't
have to you don't spend money you spend
leads you spend beads
so you they give you beads and you take
one off they're like little orange beads
oh physical beads
okay physical beads yeah physical beads
weird one time i'm weirder one time i
was in vegas and i always like to
i always used to like to buy beads in
vegas and just have them around my neck
because he feels like oh party mode
right
doesn't have like a shot glass attached
to it yeah there's a bunch you know like
little party hat with shot glass bunch
of [ __ ] right
so i was at the pool and this girl was
like can i have some beads i was like
you gonna like like northern style
she's like sure and then went to a
little corner and she showed me your
boobies and i gave her my beads and it
was
cool what a pleasant transaction you
didn't get to do it you just you wanted
to see it no no i was just i was just
like you know like the regular beads
transaction but how long did you get to
see him for
was there time it was a good like it's
like
was it enough to memorize they were
pleasant
i have a i have a uh i like your 12 joe
joe
it troubles me to hear this from you
because it sounds so very creepy
it does what if i was asking him do i
just need to memorize him for
the beads the beads okay this could have
been club med currency
because here's the thing right if you
don't if you don't if you get it like
flash right there you're like
i didn't even get enough to memorize it
right but then you're shy
dude i'm never doing business you're
getting if you get enough you're like
oh okay thank you oh that was one don't
flash
worth my money it's not worth it worth
my money i'm glad i found this side out
of him now
yeah why is that creepy i don't think
it's creepy who said it was creepy
he said it's creepy i think it was
creepy creepy
did you get you memorized i'm a
businessman that's why i said you sound
like you're 12
man like yeah but a 12 year old who
would value that
a smart 12 year old he would value that
he because what are you going to do show
me your boobs oh
i missed it oh i had to get my money's
weight yeah i blinked i [ __ ]
i was looking at the drink over there
joe you know what i take it back spoken
like a businessman thank you
i'm a businessman i'm a businessman
i want a fair transaction you know what
i mean three dollar beads though
but were they were they were they one of
those boobs where you look at it and you
go
[ __ ] i wish i could get a refund one of
them
the left one was like that's defected
yeah has anyone ever done that we're
like yo give me my beads back
you're at new orleans and you're like
wait i didn't want to see that
you don't have to throw those back sorry
not feeling that nipple right there
can't have hairy nipples get them back
or it's like half a titty
not even how far was your walk from when
you guys met to the corner because
i want to know what that conversation
was between it was a it was i feel like
i was
uh reclining and then she just
approached me and she was like can i
have beat
can you like beats and i was like sure
let's just speak english
um you know it's all kind of a blur
except for the boobs i remember the
boobs no no
you got his money's worth yeah he got
his money's worth and also well i
remember oh she had sunglasses
trucker hat yeah oh so she must have
been hot because it covered
you know trucker hats are make make
people hot
uh hats do yes okay yeah if a guy wears
hats
yeah or if girls wear big glasses make
sure the guy takes off his hats he could
really see what you're working with and
the girls have to take off the big
glasses
right because it covers up like half
their face yeah yeah i didn't care i
just want to see your boobs
okay and they were nice see that's how
guys work
you're gonna give a [ __ ] about what's
happening now we don't even i don't
think she
wants to see the titties we see the
titties he forgot her face yeah a
headless woman so we started doing this
thing
because every single time we have a
funny catchphrase everyone's like oh my
god you got to turn that into a shirt
guess what all of your prayers have been
answered
pencils power [ __ ] just like in this
video that was super hilarious
but the best part of all you could get
it right now
and relive the moment and everyone's not
gonna know this
only us who saw the video so go check it
out
link down below vessels power [ __ ] and
let people know that you care about the
three p's
the way that we do bb
[Music]
you